GOING TO BE VINDICATED.
THEY ALREADY HAVE BEEN BASED ON
THE DATA.
IT POINTS TO, DANA, A LARGER
COLONEL TOURAL SCHISM HERE.
WE NEED TO END ALL COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
THERE ARE KIDS RIGHT NOW GOING
TO SCHOOL IN PHILADELPHIA
HAVING TO WEAR MASKS.
THIS IS MADNESS.
THERE IS CONTROVERSY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. OVER WHETHER
UNVACCINATED KIDS CAN EVEN
ATTEND SCHOOL.
WE HAVE KIDS I BELIEVE IN HEAD
START PROGRAMS, VERY YOUNG KIDS
STILL BEING REQUIRED TO WEAR
MASKS.
THERE SHOULD BE ZERO COVID
RESTRICTIONS ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY.
COVID SHOT OR NOT COVID SHOT.
THIS IS MADNESS THAT WE STILL
HAVE IT.
>> Trace: IT'S AMAZING.
>> Dana: CLAY TRAVIS.
CHECK HIM OU